gridiron genius a master class and
winning championships and building
dynasties in the NFL written by Michael
Lombardi who has been alongside folks
like Bill Walsh Bill Belichick Al Davis
among others in belcheck who wrote the
foreword of the book for the author who
is here in studio Michael Lombardi good
to see you sir
thank you rich appreciate how long how
long did it take for Belichick to write
the foreword after you asked he come
back it probably took about a week yeah
it was in the offseason I asked him I
asked him before I started writing the
book he said he would do it and then I
didn't ask him until after this after
the suit not a couple weeks after the
Super Bowl he wrote it so he did his job
when you this job when he was asked yeah
his trusty Mac computer he has it and he
typed it out and sent it to me was great
I really appreciate it was tremendous
for him to do that for me I really
appreciate it and you were alongside him
and and Walsh and an Al and I want to
get into some of the stories that's
inside great gridiron genius but I want
to also hit you on a couple of topics
that I just already started the show
with right now the idea of starting a
rookie first-round quarterback I you
know I know it's obviously a lot of gray
areas whether somebody's ready or not
whether they should be put in or not
it's just a yes or no question in our
poll question I think yes what do you
say to that well I think you know the
word ready is always interesting because
were you ever ready to buy your first
house the answer was no but you bought
it anyway right and so when you draft a
quarterback that high you have to have a
plan for him Bill Walsh would always
talk about the plan for the player you
draft whether it's the quarterback the
running back what is the plan and I
think that when you draft a quarterback
that early you you have to have a plan
for him and you need him to play right
away those reps are important and this
is another wall schism is he would
rather play a rookie in September and
lose games because he knew in December
that rookie would be much better and he
would win games when it counted the most
I think we're at a point in the NFL
because of the new rules in the way we
can't really train players you know when
you first started covering the league
and I first started got in the league
there were two a day practices and it
was training camp was grueling and it
was a six-week endeavor
now we're really it's like an in season
schedule basically so there's not enough
time so September is still a
little bit of the preseason you're still
trying to get your way out look the Rams
haven't played Jared Goff yet Oakland
Los Angeles the the Raiders very little
with David Carr now maybe week three
they will Brady played a whole half last
week Russel Wilson played a whole laughs
everybody's managing their team
differently no right or wrong answer
but your team really won't come into
full force until the end of September
and I think that's why you need to play
these young guys in September so the
answer is generally yes players say yes
I mean I think unless the games way too
big now look the head coach has a tough
job he's got to stand in front of his
team and say here's our quarterback and
he gives us the best chance to win and
if the guy hasn't demonstrated any of
those skills during practice you can't
do it but I think what you see from Josh
Allen what you see from Sam Donald are
enough where the head coach can stand in
front of his team and not lose any
credibility and say this is our guy and
then we're going forward now look
quarterbacks like baseball stadiums you
got to build your team around them and
so once you quit the once you make
Joshua on the starter now you tell that
offense around what he can do and what
he can't do what once you name Sam
Donald the starter you tell her the
offense around and what he can and can't
do and now all of a sudden you're headed
in the right direction and I think
that's really what needs to happen what
do you think's going on in Cleveland we
had Jeff Schwartz on last week and I
really enjoy you know his burgeoning
voice in our business right eight years
in the league playing offensive line he
says he doesn't understand why Mayfield
doesn't get time with the ones I mean
how I don't know is that I don't either
they're 1 in 31 over the last two years
look they're if they get six wins it's
gonna be it's gonna be a lot of Bud
Light and it's gonna be historic right
so you know Billy dilly you know and so
I think that to me the quicker they get
on with it now I think that the dilemma
here is John Dorsey didn't hire Hugh so
Hugh's an inherited head coach there so
there's a little bit of like if I play
this guy do I if I play Baker and I lose
is this guy gonna fire me or if I don't
so there's some of that I think it comes
back to the plan I think there's a scene
in Hard Knocks that it just you have to
have a plan for every player and when
Hugh goes up to Baker in a kind of a
passive-aggressive way and says well
what time do you get in the morning like
that tells you as a fan and
as an executive that the kid hasn't been
told what he needs to do there's no plan
for him so I think there has to be a
plan like here's Baker you're the
starter here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna run this offense because three
years from now we're gonna be really
good and you're gonna be the starting
quarterback look Tom Landry did this
with the Dallas Cowboys he wanted to
play the Flex and at that point in the
NFL nobody was playing the Flex defense
and so his team was running the Flex and
everybody was saying we can't run the
Flex we're not any good and Landry would
always say to people when we get good
the Flex will be good we need to learn
how to run it right now and I think
that's the perfect example for young
quarterbacks especially Baker Mayfield
let's play him look I love Tyra I tell
her there's no coach that has coached
Tyrod Taylor that hasn't loved them in
terms of his person and his demeanor and
his work ethics those are all good
things and all good role models from
Baker Mayfield
however that being said the future of
the Browns really lies with Baker
Mayfield well I mean they drafted him
first overall and by the way it's
apparently torrid Tyrod he's never he's
never he's never referred to himself
around you as Terada no III
the things in the books I'm so bad at
names we nicknamed everybody because I
was so bad at pronouncing your name so I
just said just nickname everybody with
it I want to dive a little deeper so you
see on Hard Knocks that Hugh Jackson
goes up to Baker and asks um what time
that he's in in a passive-aggressive way
meaning that I'm telling you right now
you're not in early enough like I'm not
seeing first in last out on you Baker
Mayfield right it means that Hugh
Jackson and the Browns have not told
Baker like isn't that an issue that if
you have to tell somebody you need to be
first in last out I mean I think these
kids need to learn how to be pros right
somebody's got to teach them so why
isn't Tirat or or drew on doing it
that's not his job I think look look I
you know I think the job comes from the
leader of the organization the leader
sets the culture you know they all talk
about we got to change the culture here
in Cleveland I think the leadership of
the team the head coaches of responsible
for the culture I mean every day
Belichick walks into the office he's
about maintaining that culture we all
talk about the Patriot culture well that
just isn't in the building it just isn't
in the in the walls it's developed and
maintained every single day and when
it's not things start to slip and if and
it comes back to it so I think you know
you need to be direct with players need
to know exactly what you expect from
them they they want truth and honesty
look every time I ever had to release a
player I wasn't gonna sit there and say
well you know I thought you're a good
player but the coaches didn't like the
players who respect honesty just be be a
man beyond look you get in here
six o'clock every morning you know I
mean that conversation had that been in
New England it would have been a little
different would have been you know uh
Baker you probably gonna run thirteen
today so you start getting in it you
know like your job is accountable for
your actions that's how I see it Michael
Lombardi here on the Rich Eisen show I'm
gonna take a 60-second break come back I
want to hear some names of players you
think you need to take a great leap from
year one a or two or just from the draft
to year one which teams you particularly
like this year and then a couple of
stories about Walsh and Al Davis your
favorites from gridiron genius that
again is available for pre-order where
books are sold right now back with
Michael and Bharti in sixty Seconds that
was quite a throw by Patrick mahomes
over the weekend Michael Lombardi that
kids got a good arm and he's got I'll
say it and I know that this is the
highest praise you can give somebody a
Rodgers type ability to uncork a throw
on the run that you don't think he could
throw from the angle that he's got or
from his body yeah in the sessioning in
basketball they they evaluate players if
they can shoot off one foot and they can
make shots like that that's really
critical in the NBA and in football it's
critical to be able to throw the ball
from any position of your body then make
it accurate throw some guys can and some
guys can't my home's obviously Ken I
think the fascinating thing about the
Chiefs just watching them in the first
two preseason games is they're sitting
on an offense that we don't know yet I
mean Andy Reid is hiding a lot of things
what do you mean well the he's coming
out with his typical last year's offense
but he knows mahomes last year when Alex
Smith came to the line of scrimmage he
had a lot of things he had to get done
in 20 seconds he had to change the mic
he had to put the protection on he they
were always in two plays he had to get
him in the right play changed the
cadence it was a lot of things going on
that's not gonna be mahomes this game
Holmes this game is going to come down
to gonna make explosive plays down the
field and so I think what you're gonna
from Andy is a little shift in what he's
doing and he's got enough skill players
to allow him to make it the game easier
from a homes to read it and understand
where he's going with the football so
the Chiefs are going to have a great
offensive year you believe I think if
their protection and their offensive
line can hold up well it's usually what
they they have right isn't that that for
yeah well I mean the first preseason
game they they struggled but I think
this game was much better against
Atlanta
you know look Andy's a really good
quarterback coach but Andy's was able to
do if you watch Andy and Philadelphia
with Donovan McNabb a lot of play-action
a lot of what we call cross boot where
he would really fake it and reset up
McNabb behind the tackle not behind the
quarterback so he could high-low read it
and make it easier for him and he was
very good same thing he did with Alex
Smith he did things for Alex Smith that
were tailored for what he could do and I
think he'll do the same thing from
Holmes
III I think I said this to you in the
back room rich we're in a period of time
in the NFL that's really it's quietly
getting unnoticed we are in a period of
having some incredible quarterback play
from maybe it's gonna be mahomes but I
know it's gonna be deshaun Watson and I
know it's gonna be Jimmy Garoppolo it's
gonna be probably Derek Carr he's gonna
be able to do some things so this
there's so many great young quarterbacks
I think the league isn't talking about
it enough we're talking about too many
other things bortles including my
favorite subject blake i'll you know you
really I mean you look I think barreled
that kid and he's I thought me endowment
effects there you know the endowment
effect in business is when you when you
have so much invested in a player you
don't see the other side right and I
think that you know look Blake took him
to a first half against New England that
was really good and then the second half
they couldn't really finish the game off
and they're all in on Blake but if I I
keep looking if they had to Sean Watson
in the Jacksonville what would you say
it puts some names in Jacksonville and
ask yourself that question how good
would they be
well what about Bridgewater who may be
available in the next couple of weeks
what do you think the Jets are gonna do
there well I think the Jets have to sit
there and listen to every offer they can
they're gonna they have to start Sam
Donald they drafted Sam Donald to be
their franchise player we talked about
that in the last segment so I think
Bridgewater to me if you're the Tampa
Bay Buccaneers and you know that Jameis
Winston is in a contract year you know
that Ryan Fitzpatrick's the backup
quarterback wouldn't it behoove you to
trade a second-round pick because
people often get confused if I trade you
a - for a player I'm not giving you
something that I'm not getting I'm
getting a player back right right I'm
getting a starting caliber quarterback
who won 11 games in 2015 average 7.3
yards per attempt had four comeback
victories in that in his career
I mean Teddy Bridgewater has proven that
he's back to be in 15 form he's out
there he's moving around he's throwing
the ball accurately he's done the things
that he had to do to prove to the NFL
that he hasn't lost anything from 15 to
now would you if your Jacksonville I
know I I would if I was talking about
but jackals never gonna do it because
the endowment effect they're they
believe in they they have so much
invested in Blake that they're never
they can't see the other side and I
think it's gonna be their Achilles heel
who else should go for Bridgewater you
think how about Denver you know I mean
we saw Case Keenum right now I don't
know where they are with Case Keenum
they they're hired you know and we know
Paxton Lynch hasn't played well he got
over the week I think Chad Kelly I think
Chad Kelly has played really well you
know I think he has a chance to be a
really good NFL player young back maybe
perhaps a backup starter so you know how
about the New York Giants Pat Sherman
knows teddy bridgewater really well Eli
Manning's at the at the towards the end
I mean look the Giants are gonna take a
lot of heat if Donald is as good as
everybody suspects
even if Berkeley that yeah the our
conversation agree that that darn 'old
'he's blossoming in the building right
in their front porch might put some
pressure on I think Barclays gonna take
something it's gonna be great sound of
the conversation do we take a
quarterback or we take a running back I
think and if and that's gonna be the
thing you got to figure out if they can
transition from Eli to another player
without having any downtime then they
won't take that heat but if they can't
they will Michael Lombardi a host of
great pod that you can check out on on
Apple and all the other pod place where
podcasts are available and then gridiron
genius Michael and Barty here a book
that's available for pre-order who do
you think is gonna take a big leap this
later look I think DeSean Watson and
Jimmy Garoppolo that game was really fun
to watch I think they're gonna take a
huge leap Houston is a sleeping giant
because they cut their defensive players
back right and they get their starting
quarterback back and they have all these
weapons on offense I think Houston's
good I mean that AF
South I know this you know Jacksonville
is really good on defense their offense
they Doug Marrone does a great job of
managing his team around what the
quarterback can and can't do and so you
got Jacksonville you got Tennessee was a
playoff team last year and then you got
Andrew Luck back at Indianapolis they
play inside in a dome that makes them a
better team right there
and so that division is really good and
so Indianapolis can take a giant step
forward you know look Jon Gruden as a
head coach comes into a team that if he
gets it organized and cleared up they
have the 25th easiest schedule in the
NFL going in the season I think there's
the sky's the limit there - they're
gonna be much improved from where they
were so fire to give you a shot at Super
Bowl prediction what do you got for me
I like Houston I love Houston I love
Houston's team I think I love deshaun
Watson I'd love the Shaun Watson you
know since he was at Clemson and I Dabo
Sweeney named in a Michael Jordan I
think that kid's gonna be great and I
think he's gonna continue to make that
team great and that team's culture is
built around this kid's attitude I think
they're gonna be a tough out for a lot
of teams what do you got for me in the
NFC that's that's the wild card there's
so many good teams in the NFC I love
Mike Zimmer's Minnesota Vikings I think
they play in such a way but I think the
Green Bay Packers they did not look good
on defense last weekend so Mike Patton's
got a challenge ahead of him okay Josh
Jackson looks like the real deal though
but they get better but they get the
right they get the best player one of
the best players in the league coming
back whenever you add him back to your
roster so you know I think Green Bay
Houston I think it's gonna be a fun
that's what I'm saying I think we're
missing how great the league is right
now Aaron Rodgers is back you know we
got Aaron Rodgers back Big Ben's you
know still playing well in Pittsburgh
and so I like Atlanta Lambeau I like the
way that that young defense buzzes
around look at the Alvin Ridley being
added to this offense with Sanu and
Atlanta so Leo Jones in the backfield
and lattis had two ends of their
offseason the Super Bowl that they lost
51 and then last year first thing go
with the nine with a minute 14 to go in
the game and they can win the game I
mean though that that the Atlanta is
this close from basically knocking off
the Super Bowl champion and winning a
Super Bowl the play calling down there
at first and go with the 9 will always
haunt me I just
understand it you know you throw an
alley-oop in the endzone Philly has one
timeout left to go in the game if you
run the ball there Philly has two but
you might be hitting their Achilles heel
which is sarkeesian coordinating this
offense and that's what Mike that was
that was where I was leading you as you
were endorsing him I think they've got
to prove that they can manage games
correctly and their offense look nobody
was gonna make Matt Ryan as good as Kyle
Shanahan did there was going to be a
doubt Matt Ryan had to come down he had
to come back to his normal he's still a
great player but he had to come back
normally I think that there lies the
answer can they do that again and I
think that Lana you know look Atlanta
New Orleans are still the good team
they're come back there's so many good
teams in the NFC where the AFC it's a
little bit a little bit misleading that
South is good but then you got you know
Buffalo struggling Miami struggling to
kind of come back there'll be young
players and the Jets so I think and we
haven't talked about New England yeah
you know what cuz it's basically Brady
gonna remake what we think of 41 year
old quarterbacks which is it's
remarkable he's gonna he's gonna set a
standard and then the question is is is
how many wins do they have to the point
with what's their seeding and who's
gonna have the ability to go into New
England and knock him off or whom I was
gonna have a great season no matter how
great Houston's gonna be when they stare
down Tom Brady in their building where
you know he likes to win Super Bowls
plural will they be able to beat him in
their building or go to New England like
they have to go in week one and knock
them off that's a huge week one game if
you're talking about how great Houston
can be this year yeah that is just
absolutely a monster week one game in
three weeks from yesterday yeah I think
what we see from New England and week
two of this appreciation was their
defensive speed got better which is
they're gonna have to be to play a team
like Houston which can spread you
horizontally and attack you vertically
and I think that's what's gonna be the
Achilles heel of New England enough team
speed to do that okay couple minutes
let's talk about your book a gridiron
genius what's your favorite wall story
that's in here I know oh man you know
it's funny my favorite one was I got to
drive I equated it to grrah James
Corden's carpool karaoke I got to drive
him around and he would and I would
drive him somewhere and so one day he
asked me a question he said do you know
Tom Peters is and I said and I'm
thinking god he's playing a trick
question on me here this must be some
punter from
to go to state and I said I have no idea
who Tom Peters is coach and he said he's
the management guru you need to read
about Tom Peters you need to read his
book in search of excellence with Bob
Waterman and and learn from him because
if you want to be a great executive or a
great coach in this league you have to
take these ideas and he loved Tom Peters
he loved them and so that's what I did I
couldn't order it on Amazon I had
literally had to go to a bookstore at
night but I did or but you know watch
there's so much I mean the 86 draft was
it was probably my finest moment in the
NFL just watching a man work under
pressure make quick decisions and have a
Hall of Fame Draft
I mean we're sitting there at the 19th
pick in the first round rich and he
tells me to go to the chalkboard and
this is chalkboard time now it's not
grease board go to the chalkboard and
write these three names down he said
write Gerald Robinson defensive end
Oliver
Jarnell Williams running back Florida
Ronny Harmon running back Iowa and he
said well what's our time to pick we'll
take one of those three guys well the
next pick Minnesota takes Robinson the
next pick Seattle takes Williams the
next pick
Buffalo takes Harman we're out now we're
gonna pick Larry Roberts the defensive
tackle from Alabama Dolphin high school
we're gonna pick him but it's way too
early to pick them so we trade back with
Dallas and buy basically a half-hour the
next thing you know we're trading back
we're trading back we're trading back we
trade up a pick in the second round for
next year's one and we end up with Larry
Roberts Tom Rothman
Tim macaé John Taylor Steve Wallace
Kevin Fagan and oh the great Charles
Haley oh by the way the great Charles
Haley and then in the fifth round we he
gets mad that the director of college
scouting Tony Rosanna the man who hired
me tremendous tremendous man says to
bill we have to pick Patrick Miller from
Florida
it will save our draft and Bill looks at
me and says what do you think and I said
coach he tested positive at the combine
for marijuana now this is 1986 you know
there was no legalized of marijuana
anywhere in the country at that point so
that was a really huge scar back in 86
and so bill was indifferent to the idea
but he acquiesced to it and so we picked
him in the 5th round and he sly I can
still see him he slides his chair over
and he goes to the free
he goes to the free safety board and he
looks at the board and he spends maybe
about two or three minutes and he points
to this card he says Michael do you know
who this kid is here and I said oh you
mean Don Gryphon from middle Middle
Tennessee State I said yeah coach he
played free safety it's a high Valley
Conference Player of the Year he said
well when we pick in the sixth round
we're gonna pick him great so now this
is April right so there's no internet
there's no nothing
so we Neal Schmidt the area scout for
the 49ers saw him September the 21st I
think Ernie plank saw him September the
29th we don't know if I mean this kid
could not be on planet Earth at this
point so I rushed back to the to get him
and I call him on the phone and said Don
and I could hear everybody in the
audience talking and yeah yeah I'm good
I'm healthy I'm everything's good ok
we're gonna pick you if our pick in the
6th round so we pick him he ends up bill
meets him and says let's just put him a
corner see if he can play corner what
wait and he we hit in that draft room
and this is the Bradford Dillman the old
TV actor you love us a draft guru he
loved the draft and he was a huge 49er
fan so bill let him come in the draft
room and this is when we had 12 rounds
so the draft started at 5:00 in the
morning Pacific time and it would go to
2:00 in the morning 3:00 in the morning
you know when all day and Bradford would
stay in there the whole time
so in this draft we had so many picks we
picked so many players that bill
announced after we picked Don Griff and
he said look Bradford you've got the
next pick in the 10th round it's your
pick and Bradford was just as cool and
calm as can be
opens up his open up his briefcase and
he hands out a piece of paper and he's
got and the guy that he picks he wants
to pick Harold Holman defensive tackle
from Auburn and he has a complete
write-up about him and he says he gets
more penetration than Warren Beatty at a
sorority party uh and so he writes that
in there I can still remember the line
and so he says it and and so we draft
him and we draft him and he goes to
Cannon and makes all play all conference
play makes all-american in Canada all
those years gridiron genius that's just
one of the stories it's just one of them
available for pre-order right where
books are sold
Lambeau you thanks for coming in oh
thank you rich hold up yeah back
real soon thank you God the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience